Maria has 70 pages in her notebook
she made a graph of the kinds of writing
on all the pages she has used so far how
many pages are left in Maria's notebook
so down here we have a picture graph or
pictograph showing all the pages Maria's
used so far in her notebook but we're
asked how many pages are left in Maria's
notebook so to find that out we need to
know how many she started with which it
tells us right here her notebooks
started with 70 pages and then if we
take away the ones she's used so far if
we take away however many pages she's
used so far that will tell us how many
are left in her notebook so the question
here is how many has she used so far
well we don't know exactly but we have
this picture graph that will help us
find that answer so super important on
the picture graph first is right here
and tells us that each of these pieces
of paper represents two pages in Maria's
notebook so four poems she wrote on two
pages and another two pages or she wrote
on a total of four pages about poems she
did reports on two four six eight ten
pages
she wrote stories for a lot of stories
she wrote stories on two four six eight
ten twelve fourteen pages of stories she
wrote letters on two four six eight
pages and finally she journaled on two
four six eight ten twelve pages so this
here this is the total pages she's used
so far if we combine all of these the
four four poems and ten four reports and
so on this will tell us how many pages
she's used so far then we can substitute
that in right here and we can say 70 she
started with take away what she used so
far and we'll get our final solution for
the pages left in her notebook
so let's find this total there's four
pages four poems plus ten pages four
reports 14 on stories eat more pages to
write letters and 12 pages to journal so
if we add these I'll start with the ones
two ones plus eight ones is ten ones ten
ones plus four ones is 14 plus zero more
is still 14 ones plus 4 more is 18 ones
plus now let's add our tens 110 plus
another 10 is two tens or 20 plus one
more 10 is 3 tens or 30 so she's 18 once
was 310 so 18 plus 30 pages which is a
total of 48 pages she's used 48 pages so
far so if we take those 48 away from 70
we'll know how many pages are left one
way we could do this is we could think
of it as counting up we could say
there's 48 pages used let's count up to
70 to see how many more pages are still
are in the notebook if we count up from
48 to 50 that's two more pages she has
and then from 50 to 70 is 20 that's 20
more pages she has so she has a total of
22 more pages left in her notebook